I have to confess I I don't know how
dazzling I convene under the
circumstances just because I flew in and
has spoken to some of you this morning I
flew in and and it was thought I was
being very responsible I flew in that
day in advance to get acclimated and of
course jet lag
waited until this morning and so I've
been up since about 4:00 so anything I
say that that is incoherent is not at
all about my research but it's really a
pleasure to be here it's a pleasure to
be back in the Northeast I grew up here
I'm originally from Jamaica which I'll
say a little bit more about but there's
something as wonderful as it is to live
in Honolulu there's something really
warm and comforting and familiar about
being in the Northeast so I'm glad to be
here and I'm really glad to be able to
be here and have a discussion about some
of the issues that I'm working on that
may seem quite far away but are still
quite relevant to all of us even here
thousands of miles away from the Pacific
the lights down oh okay right here all
right
here we are so what I'm talking about
today's climate induced migration and I
the talk is based on some research I did
in response to a very specific question
asked two years ago the Republic of the
Marshall Islands approached the center
for climate change law at Columbia
University and asked them for help in
dealing with some of the authority or
questions that are posed by climate
impacts in their region and specifically
to their country and because this was a
solutions oriented type of conference I
had a very clear mandate he said we need
you to respond to the question of
statelessness and the issues that arise
when islands that have no longer have
inhabitable land and their citizens are
dispersed in myriad locations across the
globe what do we do about that
circumstance how do we respond to that
from legal perspective and so in this
talk I'm going to provide an overview
both of the issue of climate induced
migration which I know some of you are
familiar with but I want to introduce
you to that and and then again look at
it from the perspective that I looked at
it particularly in trying to conceive of
a
a reasonable and viable solution for the
challenge of statehood that's
represented in some of the kinds of
migration that we'll see so here's how
I'll proceed and I'm hoping to do this
in about just under 30 minutes but I
want to give a brief overview of climate
change science and the forecasting and
how that impacts what I'll be talking
about and then I want to look at the
challenges of climate induced migration
and highlight some of the issues that
exist in the conversation about
migration and climate change and then
then I'll sort of drill in deeper to
this question of migration sovereignty
and statelessness and and sort of
introduce you to my thought process on
how to allow for landless nation-states
to continue to have international
personality and what I argued in my
article called the nation accede to was
that to respond to the phenomenon of
landless nation-states international law
must accommodate an entirely new
category of international actors and I
called them nations accede to and what I
was envisioning in the accede to
statehood is that you would be able to
have as a country a continued existence
as a sovereign state afforded all the
rights and benefits of sovereignty
amongst the families of of nations and
nation states in perpetuity and what I
knew and thinking through this is that
in practice you'd have to be able to
govern a region or rather lack of a lack
of a territory but exercise authority
over to view diffuse people's right
people that are all over the world but
still maintain sort of some sort of
governance structure so that you can
enjoy the rights and privileges of being
a state at the international community
and I also conceived of this of a new
kind of trusteeship system that would
allow for that kind of diffuse
governance it's a framework that I use
an analogous structure that I I add to
the discourse on and I and I try to do
this first with a disclaimer which is
that in thinking about trusteeship sui
are not are certainly I'm not suggesting
that there should be any kind of new
colonial relationship or governance and
infrastructure introduced but a way of
thinking about how to govern added heard
her last state is what I'm getting at
right so I do two different but
inextricably intertwined thing
in the paper and I'll briefly do it in
the talk given time first I attempt to
define and justify the recognition of de
territory alized nation-states
and then I briefly explain the
trusteeship arrangement and how you
would govern the xc2 nation and again
it's after this brief overview of
climate science which some of you may
know better than I do I've soaked some
of her to doing the environmental
sciences but essentially we are talking
about our impacts on the global
environment right we're altering the
chemistry of the atmosphere and the
research is happening actually right
next door to where I live we used to be
at 287 parts per million of carbon in
the atmosphere before the Industrial
Revolution but scientists at Mount aloe
Observatory and on the Big Island of
Hawaii say that carbon dioxide levels in
the atmosphere as of this year have
touched daily averages of 400 parts per
million right that's up 40% more than
the Industrial Revolution and the
highest released the last 650,000 years
and the impacts are quite severe and the
cover of this issue of new scientists
and the entire issue was devoted to the
fact that the impacts are worse than we
thought they were right and for
non-scientists Lord Nicholas turn really
summarizes some of the impacts and the
gravity of them quite well the emissions
are growing faster than we thought the
absorption capacity of the planet is
less than we thought
the probability of high temperatures is
likely higher than we thought and some
of the effects are coming faster than we
thought and oftentimes in climate talks
we see the evidence right and the
evidence is usually the breakup of
glaciers and ice sheets and we'll see
images of glaciers this is one in Peru
in 1980 and then in 2003 all right and
we're seeing we're see that and take
away from that the stark impacts of the
heat that were introducing and then we
have images like this I actually think
this is quite beautiful but what it's
telling us this is a iceberg that's
capped from the Greenland ice sheet and
is a striking photo until you pause and
consider the implications emissions are
soaring and climate impacts around the
world are appearing with increasing
frequency and forecasts of sea level
rise are inherently uncertain but are
postulated to be closer to one meter
between
one hundred as a conservative number and
that's much more than the initial
estimates from the IPCC the most recent
have gotten closer to that number but
still was there's some suggestion that
the kind of sea level rise we'll see
will be greater than what's currently
forecast and the implications for that
melting and warming for the most
vulnerable and particularly hot spots
like small island states in the Pacific
and in the Indian Ocean that it's
considerable and in fact it's
existential in some cases so countries
like the Maldives Tuvalu Carabosse and
the Republic of Marshall the Marshall
Islands risk inundation and perhaps
uninhabitable 'ti prior to submersion so
looking at the migration question a
little more closely I want to pause for
a second and say that one of my
colleagues in the University of Colorado
Sarah Cray confident as well used to say
that she thought it was illegal to have
a to do a presentation on climate change
and not have an image of a polar bear so
beautifully I present the cute and
cuddly poder polar bear song with its
cub which I usually leave in my
presentation this one may be a little
bit more appropriate the bad news is
that ice cap is melting and it's going
to be almost impossible to catch seals
the good news is that if we keep moving
south there's tons of fat animals called
humans who can't run very fast right the
notion here right this demonstrates in
sort of a tongue-in-cheek fashion the
role of migration as a legitimate
adaptive response right you go to where
the meat is and this makes sense and we
in fact human if throughout human
history we've adapted to a number of
different locations and we've moved
quite a bit since our beginning and of
course the way that we've organized our
society in recent history and our
geopolitical history makes this movement
more complex for humans and the way that
we've animated the climate crisis when
we talk about it has also posed some
challenges we employ the charismatic
megafauna the large animal that's
trotted out to really sort of underscore
the enormity of the tragedy and
sometimes the exclusion of the human
impacts so while this is a very poignant
image and it's very important for us to
remember the impacts here it's also
important to understand the creeping
tragic tragedy that's happening
to to the polar bears human neighbors
right and here is one of the Canaries in
the coal mine both for the climate issue
and for migration as evidenced in the
United States Inuit communities
generally are suffering impacts of
climate change the availability of food
water shelter is increasingly
increasingly unpredictable at best and
at worst permafrost and protective sea
ice barriers are collapsing and forcing
relocation and there have been some
relocation efforts at least attempts to
relocate in partnership with the federal
government but because these are
unprecedented moves coupled with general
political lethargy and the issue several
communities relocation attempts have
been stalled for up to 10 years and
litigation efforts to gain relocation
aid from oil and gas companies have also
suffered significant setbacks I also
want to offer hurricane katrina as an
example and of course there is always
the attribution question about whether
or not we can link a particularly match
ange but let's just use this as maybe an
example of things to come if it's not
directly related and what we saw during
that time is not only the massive storm
and the total collapse of public
preparedness but we saw also the about
1.1 million people in Louisiana
permanently or temporarily displaced by
the storm two million once you added the
numbers from Rita that same year and the
FEMA spokeswoman at that time said we've
never had a situation where an entire
American city was evacuated and they
weren't able to go home these numbers
represent that phenomenon so I suggest
that we the US included are approaching
a new frontier and I think hurricane
sandy situated as squarely in that wild
space we're also seeing the phenomenon
of international migration in the United
States here there's an example of of it
sort of coming home to roost both Hawaii
and mainland u.s. is seeing some climate
driven migration from the Pacific Island
region specifically countries with which
we have a new compact migration
agreements to the compact of free
association New Zealand has been seeing
this for quite some time and actually
very recently as an
yesterday they the courts knew something
we're considering the case of a climate
a self-proclaimed climate refugee who is
seeking refuge in in New Zealand itself
so there's something here and when Sir
David King said the maps of the world
will have to be redrawn he was speaking
as a scientist knew speaking about
melting ice sheets but of course as
someone who's thinking of the law and
policy of it all and the geopolitics of
it all this is an incredibly powerful
statement and it's true in our world as
well so there's something there I
present this slide which is meant to
show an estimation of the number of
people that will move and in the
millions
based on the sea-level rise by meters
but I show this purely to convey the
upper trend because the numbers are
likely totally wrong all right and I use
this because it's it it's a heart of
some of the difficulty of understanding
migration which is we don't really know
how many people were talking about when
it comes down to it it's impossible to
know the actual numbers for for a few
reasons which I can address in the Q&A
but even the the most commonly cited
number is offered by Norman Myers he's
an Oxford ecologist he says it's about
200 to 250 million by 2050 but he said
to get to that number involved heroic
extrapolations so he was essentially
admitting that he did a lot of guessing
to get to this number
but the guesstimate are really quiet
unwieldy we have everything from 50
million to 1 billion people depending on
the study you look at and that's sort of
an impossible range to plan for or to
prepare against but if we take the
commonly cited number of 200 and 250
million for perspective we can imagine a
good chunk of the US population which is
about 300 million now potentially on the
move or having moved by 2050 and we can
also compare that to the current number
of migrants which the international
organization of migration has estimated
to be about 200 million worldwide so the
numbers issue is difficult and it's
really difficult to know but what we do
know is that it's already occurring
within countries or some examples in the
United States certainly South Asia or
internal migration and in the Pacific
region
Pacific island nations internally as
well as across borders the other thing
that we know is that the circumstances
of small island states that risk
complete loss of territory is distinct
and distinct enough from the larger
experience of climate induced
displacement that it deserves to be
carved out and dealt with separately and
rapidly but migration generally has been
a political hot potato but it's
critically important as I hope I'll
prove for for the law to address the
phenomenon now to kind of give you some
context to how I think about these this
kind of issue
professor David Caron wrote what I
thought was an incredibly insightful
article 23 years ago called the one law
makes climate change worse rethinking
the law of basslines and let have sea
level rise he was talking about policies
related to that the law of the sea but
the message the vehicle that he uses the
conceptual vehicle uses I think is
incredibly helpful we can think about
the laws having relevance to climate
change and capacity to do something
about climate change in some very clear
ways right when when the Sierra Club
sues to stop the building of coal-fired
power plants we see that as law acting
right and in furtherance of mitigation
efforts when we work to help and design
and implement state programs to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions like our state
program in Hawaii the global warming
solutions Act lawyers worked on how to
make that work and how to have that sync
with other areas of governance in the
state but there are many instances where
the absence of law or the necessary
amendments to law that aren't happening
exacerbate poor climate forecasts for
individuals and communities and what
Karen is essentially saying is that you
can understand these as non natural
legal feedbacks
he's obviously borrowing from the
climate scientists who talk about
positive feedback loops in which one
natural process that's disrupted by
climate change accelerates the impacts
of climate change so he's talking about
this as sort of a positive feedback loop
and how he just explains it as as
follows legal feedbacks will not alter
the amount of climate change will
aggravate the suffering that will
accompany such change the greater the
change the greater the aggravation
I think this is totally right on I have
one footnote though which is to say that
now that were 23 years past 1990 in fact
legal feedbacks have altered the amount
of climate change are the absence of an
aggressive binding agreement the the
success the failure of Kyoto essentially
and the absence of a successor agreement
has actually increased the amount of
climate change will certainly increase
the emission that works we're going to
experience but of course there are other
feedbacks that are relevant here
unresolved questions regarding migration
definitions and classifications of
migrants lack of clarity regarding the
resettlement rights just in this issue
of migration is going to be important
and the absence of any legal mechanism
is making the situation worse and that's
true too when we think about the context
of statelessness statelessness presents
an aggravating legal feedback so one of
the things i mentioned was the absence
of a definition and you I'm sure mostly
heard climate the term climate refugees
to describe this phenomenon of climate
induced migration or climate migrants
and it's important to remember that a
refugee can be defined in different ways
depending on your discipline in your
perspective it has a political and
sociological relevance if it's
describing a political phenomenon or our
migration as an empirical reality or
wanting refuge as an empirical reality
but legally what's stipulated in
national or international law it's not
there where there is no such thing as a
climate refugee all right the Refugee
Convention is really dealing with
different kinds of circumstances and to
argue otherwise is a little a bit
difficult although there is some
argument in that and that realm but
essentially you have a couple of
important hurdles which is that refugee
status usually involve some sort of
state-sponsored persecution based on
identity and urgency right you have to
leave and there's no choice and and
that's why it's important that the
absence of climate refugees as a legal
term is is going to be a significant
hurdle professor Jane macadam basically
said legal definitions bind States in
ways that descriptive labels cannot so
by simply calling them climate refugees
we are not actually able to
I respect their rights and and and sort
of exercise obligations as a result of
those rights so that's going to be a
different and difficult type of hurdle
that they will have to overcome so you
must ask and many of the islands have
asked how do you make policy underwater
how do you have your rights recognized
underwater this was obviously an
important publicity stunt for the
Maldivian government in 2009 right
before the Copenhagen agreement of
meetings rather they decided to have a
cabinet meeting underwater to sign a
declaration or you know sort of eagerly
requesting that there would be a fair
ambitious and binding agreement at the
Copenhagen meetings right and
considering their circumstances you can
understand why they would do that this
is male this is the capital of the
Maldives at its highest point is about
eight feet this is an incredibly
stressed community right now it's an
atoll nation that's looking at the
possibility of losing all of its
territory of all of its habitable
territory and so they're certainly going
to ask for a legally recognised
definition of this of their status a
clear statement of their rights a
determination of what currently exists
to address international and internal
migration and key to this talk what to
do about statelessness right and usually
statelessness is dealing with
deprivation of nationality right it's
not designed to deal with situations
where no successor state exists and
predecessor states have disappeared it
has disappeared and in the cases of
what's forecast for some of these island
nations so other questions come up that
are really difficult when does the
nation cease to be a nation can you
maintain a government much less than
identity if your land can no longer be
inhabited questions
so the relative near-term dissolution of
a country's habitable territory due to
climate change is what I refer to as
endangered the - as the endangered
States problem right and some you may
hear drowning staged drowning islands
threatened islands but the endangered
States phenomenon represents novel
questions that challenge the very
foundation of Westphalia in our nation
state sovereignty and the countries at
issue in particular are mostly in the
Pacific they are again
Tuvalu Carabosse the Republic of the
Marshall Islands and of course in the
Indian Ocean the Maldives which you
can't see here in this image someone
asked me once I gave this if I had
Australia sort of out in the middle for
a reason I don't but it's really
important to think about the regional
dynamics here the question then is what
we do about statehood in this context we
are bound by prior understandings of
what a state is and generally speaking
to be a state you have to have four key
elements permanent population defined
territory a functioning government and
the capacity to enter into relations
with other states recently I shared this
with someone who reminded me that given
a functioning government as a
requirement perhaps United States might
be excluded but let's first I can assume
that that's not the case we definitely
understand that some things are are we
we have a sense that some things are
indispensable and there's certainly a
strong argument that territories one of
those elements of statehood that's
indispensable but de territorial i's
statehood as an alternative for
endangered States has been offered as a
possibility before not by many but it's
certainly been offered and others have
contemplated having such a successor
entity in particular rosemary refuse who
is actually a professor of law and in
Australia and there is actually a very
strong scholarship that's amount of
scholarship that's coming out of that
region for obvious reasons on this
question but she briefly introduced the
possibility and argued that ultimately a
more equitable solution may lie in
recognition of a new category of de
territory alized state right that this
is maybe the equitable approach and that
was an important introduction
but scholars generally have not
elaborated on what that would mean nor
of they provided justification for the
kind of new category of international
personality that she's recommending and
that I agree is a possibility so that's
what I'm doing in the nation accede to
and the first piece again I said is to
sort of figure out what it is what is
data is and then justify why we could we
could maybe in these cases relax the
territory requirement they make three
basic arguments to support the creation
of this new category the first is that
the alternative forms of the state are
not necessarily novel there are
historical analogues all right I should
say when I say stay it also made sort of
a international entity that sometimes
acts and looks like a state there are
historical analogues they're rough but I
think they're relevant and I'll say a
little bit more about that then I also
argue that elements of cosmopolitan
theory as well as the evolving
conditions of various diaspora prove
that a landless or virtual nation is
appropriate here and is at the same time
an inevitable evolution of contemporary
citizenship and statehood and I say this
and I want to be careful not to be too
carefree I I'm from Jamaica originally
as born in Kingston and there's a
difference between my experience of
diaspora then someone whose state has
disappeared I could go back to Kingston
if I chose to write so I don't want to
draw the the I don't want to make it too
close finale' G but I do think there's a
blueprint here that's really important
to consider and I'll say more about that
as well but if those two aren't
persuasive I argue that the
extraordinary circumstances of
threatened Nations alone justify such
unique departures from the norm so first
looking at this alternative forms of
state there are a few instances where
international actors kind of provide
helpful precedent for the de territory
alized nation idea they the first is
countries that are ready governed
without a territory or failed States and
governments in exile and economic
entities that serve quasi governmental
roles like the the EU and I'll say a
little bit more about the first two here
the first is this notion of countries
that have governed
or international actors that govern like
and act like countries that have no
territory you might have heard of the
Sovereign Order of Malta anyone yeah all
right excellent
have you been right well in fact you
can't go to the sovereign Order of Malta
right because the sovereign order lost
access to the island of Malta almost two
years ago 200 years ago rather and and
had to forge a different kind of
relationship with the international
community it's still a sovereign subject
of international law it has its own
government it's based in Rome and
essentially an office and virtually on
the web it has an independent Majesty it
has bilateral diplomatic relations with
104 countries it's granted the status of
permanent observer and a number of
international organizations including
the United Nations and it has a pretty
interesting or robust way of becoming
more familiar with the country as in its
faq page right frequently asked
questions this is the extent of the
Sovereign Order of Malta and it's been
used I think I think is a very
interesting and important way of
considering how one can still be an
important international actor yet have
lost territory years and years ago the
other example that I want to offer is
the is Tibet right governments in exile
in 2011 there was an election for the
new Tibetan president if 55,000 Tibetans
were scattered around the world and
participated in this election and I
offer this example to show that we can
glean important governance lessons from
highly how other highly disparate
communities are organized and governed
right so the mechanics of coordinating
physically disconnected civic
participation is demonstrated through
the relationship that Tibetans have with
their government again even though they
are dispersed people if you consider the
cosmopolitan theory and the experience
of diaspora they serve as a
counterweight to neat understandings of
statehood land and citizenship and the
notion that they are inextricably
interlinked what's important to remember
it seems to me is that climate change
acts on this world right even though
we've organized ourselves into this
world and so borders are superimposed
and they are in some respects if you
will
non natural legal feedback mechanisms
right thankfully though unlike the laws
of physics they are not immutable or
static they are laws of society and
humanity and should be more variable the
consistent and more malleable given a
circumstances they should be in light of
climate change a little bit more
forgiving and I argue that contemporary
global movement has already forced a
rethinking beyond the nation
traditionally marked by borders and
dividing walls and that the experience
of diverse in multiple diaspora make the
cosmopolitan framework uniquely relevant
to 21st century experiences of land and
state for groups and individuals and in
this context it becomes clear that the
territory lies statehood is not
necessarily far-fetched and in fact
there may already be a rough blueprint
of its normative infrastructure in the
diverse scholarship of cosmopolitan
theory post-colonial migration in
particular has produced a particular
kind of of citizenship while citizenship
is generally understood to be
territorially bound post-colonial
citizenships tend to be de territory
alized and maintained through travel
pilgrimage labor migration other complex
residential patterns that traverse
boundaries and territorial boundaries
and identity aren't necessarily
reflected clearly in the global
migration that we're seeing that
produces citizens that are actually
exercising substantive citizenship in
more than one place some cases at least
two states perhaps more citizens can
enjoy long-distance bonds with natives
from which they've long immigrated and
have a strong cultural connection as a
result of their shared history and I
offer as an example my own my own
experience largely because if you've
ever met a Jamaican and you know we have
a very strong diaspora and a strong
identity and in fact the population of
Jamaica is 2.9 million but to 2 million
to two and a half million identify as
Jamaican here maintain strong
relationships in spite of the fact that
they are not located in the same place
they're critical lessons of diaspora
communities
convey right you don't necessarily
relinquish substantive citizenship or
connection or trans found you trans
boundary allegiances because you're not
on the same place right it's viable
therefore to conceive of a nation that
is both dispersed and to territorial
eyes based on the strong example of
diaspora and even the Pacific we are
already seeing very strong examples of
how the migration quarters are producing
a strong diaspora in the in the US as
well as in New Zealand in Australia that
the numbers I don't have this is
actually I apologize for the date of the
census I was actually up looking to see
if there was an update a couple days ago
and the government shut down and not
allow me to check for the census numbers
but let's just take these numbers and I
know for example that the numbers of
marshalese in our country has increased
and we're seeing that there's a pretty
significant diasporic set of communities
that are expanding throughout the US and
certainly in the Pacific region again
the comparison is not complete again for
members of the day asked for the
existence of multiple tangible home
remains and that's significant you can
visit home Pacific Islanders in
particular generally speaking have a
strong relationship to land and
territory all right it's a critical to
their identity in marshalese language
for example the word for land and
placenta is the same all right so it is
a very stark and and and a very dramatic
event to have to consider losing your
territory and being dispersed in this
way but it seems to me that there are
some possibilities for understanding
these trans boundary loyalties to allow
for all of the rights of citizenship and
statehood to be afforded to you even
even the territory alized then I argue
in the in the article that if the above
is not persuasive I offer the following
the first is that the presumption in
international law is that states
continue right the continuity of an
existing state is is presumed and that
presumption would be logically extended
to
current endangered nations and then also
the appropriate interpretation of
existing laws and the spirit in which
they were drafted and ratified militate
in favor of expansive interpretation for
the benefit of the people of these
endangered states for example if we
think back to the Peace of Westphalia
right it was ostensibly introduced to
provide security and stability during
warring time right and that stability
and security was represented by borders
and nation states and so allowing the de
territorial eyes statehood bound by
culture and experience would perhaps
serve the objective purpose of
Westphalian system at a time when
climate change really introduces an
extraordinary threat to territorial
integrity and to global peace and
security so I'm gonna quickly sort of
map thick c2 nation and say a little bit
more about what I think are some really
indispensable elements of it right the
key features of it first I argue that to
respect the continued sovereign equality
of the endangered State the United
Nations and member states must act only
to support the transition to an
establishment of xc2 nationhood again
the trusteeship system is one that has
been offered as a possible model but the
UN and it's something the United Nations
has done before and perhaps can be
applied in this context there are
important amendments though that would
have to be made especially because if
we're to recognize the sovereignty of
these countries continue on forward we'd
have to be careful that the role of the
international community is purely to
support their existence and perhaps
collaboration rather than to govern
those those countries are the the XE two
nations the other pieces that appointed
two members of the endangered States
supported by the UN would serve as a
political trustee so this really would
be about governance over time by the
marshalese for example right there would
be an establishment of an Internet
interim mission mission and then the
permanent nation accede to status so the
intermission would then merge with a
permanent Republic of Marshall Islands
ex situ and continue the work of the
the government as it deals with
transition and this is everything from
distributing resource friends to
adaptation funding to allowing for
diplomatic relations and resettlement to
be negotiated with some sort of
government entity that would continue to
exist and then this piece I think is
really important it's member-driven and
that all of the the meetings the
decision-making would be about the
furtherance of the specific peoples and
cultures that are now detect D
territorial eyes and that might even
mean that the the members would decide
to dissolve but that's their decision
alone and that seems to me a key element
of any proposal for the territorial i's
statehood i think there are a number of
intangible benefits formal membership
can be passed down through generations
even without a physical location the
sense of bonded community will continue
to have multi-generational relevance and
strength there's also a possibility that
the Nationals of xc2 state can in tin
you to enjoy a shared purpose and Eva
seems to be the most powerful binding
force of the sovereign Order of Malta
whose members remain bonded by history
spirituality and service and then
there's a possibility for reunion in
other locations right common cultural
identity might persist and in some in
many cases this is one of the largest
fears of Pacific Islanders is that their
culture and their identity will vanish
along with their territory so in
conclusion I just wanted to offer a
quick story about how some of the ways
I've come to think about this and one is
that I was in the oceans conference with
a number of climate scientists and we're
trying to talk about a divide between
scientists and policy murder members how
we can talk about climate change more
effectively and what to do and one of
the scientists actually said the most
effective way to communicate about
climate change is not the science that
I've just offered but to talk about how
it links to our kids and our pets and
our houses and our jobs right and
immediately this image of my daughter
came up it was this is her and in
Waikiki which is a wetland by the way
and it might be again very soon and her
she's so joyful and her feet is you know
covered in water and it really struck me
as a student of post-colonial theory a
daughter of a colonial sub
and immigrant from report a former
British colony I've always hoped for a
rethinking of the Westphalian order I've
always thought about a progressive
redrawing of the world's maps and
thinking through borders and boundaries
in a way that they would be questioned
fundamentally and now that may well come
to pass but in profoundly different
circumstances than I had ever imagined
and now I find myself in the opposite
position of searching for ways to save
these borders to save imagined
communities for our our children's
generation optimally there would be
aggressive action for mitigation and we
wouldn't have to even have this
conversation many of the Islanders would
not lead me to leave where they live
right now but absent any indication of
Switch swift action in that front
international law I think must find
suitable solutions for the nation-state
problem of statelessness problem and
related issues and I offer the nation
xc2 as a point of departure thank you